हे गाइस, दिस इज़ नितेश फाउंडर ऑफ़
डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी। इस वीडियो
में दो बड़े सरप्राइज़ आपके लिए मैं अनाउंस
करने वाला हूं। पहला सरप्राइज़ के बारे में
आपको ऑलरेडी आईडिया थोड़ा बहुत मैंने दे
दिया है पहले। सेकंड सरप्राइज उससे भी बड़ी
सरप्राइज़ है। तो वीडियो बहुत छोटी रहने
वाली है। एंड डायरेक्ट मैं आपके लिए पॉइंट
पे आ जाता हूं। सबसे पहले तो हम एक एथिकल
हैकिंग की कंप्लीट वन शॉट वीडियो कोर्स
ल्च करने जा रहे हैं। जो कि पार्ट वन
होगा। पार्ट टू भी आएगा बट वो कब आएगा,
कितनी जल्दी आएगा यह आपके रिस्पांस पर
डिपेंड करता है। दूसरी सरप्राइज यह है कि
यह एक फ्री कोर्स होगा वन शॉट वीडियो।
उसके बाद भी हम आपको WhatsApp सपोर्ट
प्रोवाइड करने वाले हैं। जो आई डोंट थिंक
कि YouTube पे या एथिकल हैकिंग कम्युनिटी
के अंदर कोई भी फ्री कोर्स के लिए
प्रोवाइड करता होगा। तो यहां पे ये जो वन
शॉट वीडियो कोर्स होगा ये बाकी कोर्सर्सेस
की तरह ही नहीं होने वाला है बल्कि इसके
साथ आता है एक WhatsApp सपोर्ट ग्रुप का
आपका एक्सेस जिसको आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं।
एंड उसका लिंक जो है इसी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में एंड पिनड कमेंट में
ऑलरेडी दिया हुआ है। आप प्लीज जाइए
डिस्क्रिप्शन पिन कमेंट चेक कीजिए। उस
WhatsApp ग्रुप को जरूर से जरूर जॉइ
कीजिए। एंड अब ये जो ग्रुप्स हैं जो भी
क्योंकि बहुत सारे लोग जुड़ेंगे तो
मल्टीपल ग्रुप्स होंगे तो हमने इन ग्रुप्स
को एक कम्युनिटी के अंदर WhatsApp का जो
कम्युनिटी फीचर है उसके अंदर कर दिया है
ताकि आपके नंबर्स भी जो है हिडन रहेंगे
प्राइवेसी भी रहेगी। तो अब जो है ये जो वन
शॉट वीडियो कोर्स है जैसे ही ये वीडियो डल
जाएगी उसके बाद जो है ग्रुप्स में जितने
भी लर्नर्स रहेंगे आप अभी भी ग्रुप को
ज्वाइन कर सकते हैं और जो वीडियो जब लाइव
होगी हमारी वनशोर वीडियो कोर्स उसके भी
डिस्क्रिप्शन पिन कमेंट में आपको लिंक मिल
जाएगा। आप वहां से भी ज्वाइन कर पाएंगे।
राइट? तो अभी सबसे पहले तो आप जाके ग्रुप
को ज्वाइन कर लीजिए। अब ये ग्रुप बनाने के
पीछे मोटिव क्या है कि हमारा जो यह वन शॉट
एथिकल हैकिंग वीडियो कोर्स आने वाला है।
उसमें बहुत सारे लर्नर्स उस वीडियोस को जो
हैं वो देखेंगे। राइट? पार्ट वन अभी है
फिलहाल एंड उसमें उनको डाउट हो सकता है।
तो बाकी वीडियोस ऐसे बहुत सारे YouTube पे
आपको मिल जाएंगे। बट क्या होता है? अब
आपको डाउट है, कुछ है तो अब आप समझ नहीं
पाते कहां पूछना है, कैसे किससे बात करनी
है, डिस्कस करना है। तो इसलिए ये ग्रुप
बनाया गया है। आप ग्रुप में बाकी यूज़र्स
के साथ भी डिस्कशन कर सकते हैं। और आपके
लिए हमारे साइड से वहां पे एक ट्रेनर
होंगे जो कि आपके जो भी डाउट्स हैं जो भी
आपकी क्वेरीज हैं उन सबको रिजॉल्व करेंगे।
आपकी किसी टॉपिक में दिक्कत आ रही है,
किसी पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक में कुछ समझ नहीं आ
रहा है, कुछ आपको पूछना है, कोई क्वेरी है
तो आप ग्रुप में पूछिए और हम उसका आंसर
आपके लिए करेंगे। तो ये एक तरीके का एक
ऐसा
कोर्स होने वाला है जो कि बिगिनर फ्रेंडली
भी होने वाला है। अगर आप एथिकल हैकिंग के
अंदर में कुछ भी नहीं जानते हैं। यू नो
नथिंग अबाउट इट। आपको नहीं पता कैसे
स्टार्ट करना है। आपको नहीं पता कि किस
तरीके की स्ट्रक्चर लर्निंग आपको करनी है।
आपको नहीं पता कि कौन से टॉपिक को पहले
पढ़ना है, कौन से टॉपिक को बाद में पढ़ना
है, कैसे स्टार्ट करना है, इसमें करियर
बनाना है। कैसे एक एथिकल हैकर बनना है।
एक्चुअली जो स्किल्ड हो। तो आपके लिए ये
कोर्स है जो कि बिगिनर फ्रेंडली होगी,
हिंदी में होगी और बिगिनर टू एक
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक आपको लेकर जाएगी। एंड
उन सभी स्टूडेंट्स के लिए, लर्नर्स के लिए
है जो इवन बहुत मुश्किल से ₹1000 भी
कलेक्ट कर पाते हैं। अफोर्ड नहीं कर पाते।
इवन 500 का भी कोई कोर्स है, 1000 का भी
कोर्स है। वो उनके एफोर्ड ज़ोन से बाहर
होता है। वो अफोर्ड नहीं कर पाते हैं।
उनके लिए स्पेशली डिज़ ये हमने वन शॉट
वीडियो कोर्स बनाया है। और यह सिर्फ पार्ट
वन है। अब पार्ट टू कितनी जल्दी आएगा? कब
आएगा? यह सब आपके हाथों में मैं छोड़ देता
हूं क्योंकि पार्ट वन पे जितना अच्छा
रिस्पांस होगा पार्ट वन की वीडियो को आप
जितना शेयर करेंगे हर जगह सोशल मीडियास पे
और जितने ज्यादा लोग उसमें इंटरेस्ट शो
करेंगे कमेंट्स के थ्रू लाइक्स के थ्रू
शेयर करके उतनी जल्दी पार्ट टू हम लेकर
आएंगे। पार्ट वन में हमने बहुत सारे एथिकल
हैकिंग के टॉपिक्स, डेमोंस्ट्रेशन,
प्रैक्टिकल्स सब कुछ कवर करा है और पार्ट
टू जो आएगी वो इससे भी एक लेवल ऊपर का
होने वाला है। तो सब कुछ आपके हाथों में
है। हमारा काम है आपको एक क्वालिटी कंटेंट
प्रोवाइड करना। ऑलरेडी हम बहुत सारी फ्री
ट्रेनिंग कोर्सर्सेस के थ्रू कर रहे हैं।
और एक और ये एथिकल हैकिंग की वन शॉट
वीडियो कोर्स आपके लिए लेकर आ रहे हैं। आप
लोगों में से कई लोगों की ये डिमांड पहले
से रही है। बहुत टाइम से रही है। और हमारे
भी दिमाग में आया पहले हम इसको पेड कोर्स
की तरह सोच रहे थे लाने का कि मेंबरशिप
वाली जो होती है ना YouTube पे उस तरीके
से। बट फिर हमने उसको बिल्कुल फ्री करने
का सोचा है कि एकदम फ्री होगा। एक पैसा ₹1
आपको नहीं देना है। WhatsApp सपोर्ट के
लिए भी कोई पैसा कुछ भी नहीं देना है
आपको। तो ग्रुप को बस जाइए डिस्क्रिप्शन
पिन कमेंट में ग्रुप है उसको प्लीज इट्स अ
वेरी मैंडेटरी प्रोसेस सबसे ज्यादाेंट
प्रोसेस है ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिए उसी
ग्रुप में आप रहिए और जो भी रिसोर्सेज
होंगे इस ट्रेनिंग के रिगार्डिंग इस मतलब
वन शॉट वीडियो कोर्स के रिगार्डिंग जो भी
आपको सॉफ्टवेयर्स की जरूरत होगी जो भी
पीडीएफ रिसोर्सेज की जरूरत होगी जो भी सब
इसी ग्रुप्स में आपको मिले करेंगे एंड आप
अपने क्वेरीज क्वेश्चंस डाउट्स जो भी है
पूछ सकते हैं। सो गाइज़ जाइए इस ग्रुप को
ज्वाइन कीजिए एंड आई होप कि आपको यह एथिकल
हैकिंग की जो वीडियो आ रही है वन शॉट
वीडियो कोर्स ये आपको बहुत अच्छी लगेगी।
कई ऐसी चीजें हैं इसमें जो बहुत सारी पेड
कोर्सर्सेस में भी आपको नहीं मिलेंगी। आप
एज यूजुअल जानते हैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स के फ्री
कंटेंट जो होते हैं वो कई सारे पेड
कंटेंट्स एंड पेड कोर्सेज से भी एक लेवल
ऊपर के हो जाते हैं। तो अगर आपको यह
ट्रस्ट जो है डिफरनिश के अंदर तो
डेफिनेटली आप इस वीडियो को जरूर देखिएगा
जो आने वाली है बहुत जल्द YouTube पे लाइव
होगी। लगभग 5 1/2 घंटे की ये वीडियो वन
शॉट वीडियो कोर्स होगी और नेक्स्ट जो
पार्ट आएगा वो भी लगभग इसी अराउंड होगी।
तो लगभग 12 13 हमारा मोटिव है लगभग 15
घंटे के आसपास का यह पूरा कोर्स डेवलप
करने का आपके सामने लाने का। तो पार्ट वन
आपका 5 1/2 घंटे का है। पार्ट टू आपके ऊपर
है। कब आप लाना चाहते हैं? कब आप चाहते
हैं कि हम इतनी कितनी जल्दी उस पे काम
करना शुरू कर दें और आपके लिए लेकर आ
जाएं। तो आपके सारे सपोर्ट, प्यार और
शेयरिंग की वजह से हो पाएगा। फिर जाइए
ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिए एंड हम मिलेंगे
एथिकल हैकिंग की वन शॉर्ट वीडियो कोर्स
में आप सबके लिए बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स। थैंक यू
वेरी मच टू एवरीबॉडी फॉर सपोर्टिंग अस टिल
नाउ।